Ouais.
Donc, pour aller de l'avant, les bits
et les qubits seront les unités de calcul fondamentales
avec lesquelles on pourra s'attaquer
aux problèmes complexes du monde
alors essayons de comprendre la différence entre eux
et d'où vient la puissance des qubits
si on regarde le côté gauche
c'est une façon de décrire et on va utiliser ces diagrammes
tout au long de la présentation pour
illustrer la puissance — on voit un cercle
et deux points : quand le point est au pôle nord
c'est le zéro, quand il est au pôle sud c'est un
voilà un bit classique à deux états — maintenant un qubit c'est
l'unité d'information dans le monde quantique
et ici on a l'image d'une sphère
comme une sphère, avec zéro et un
et on peut les avoir dans cet état de superposition
on a un truc spécial qui est à notre disposition
non seulement on peut les positionner sur cette sphère
mais imagine que chacun d'eux
est comme une petite lune
qui est sur cette sphère et on peut faire tourner la lune
donc là tu vois que
la sphère du bas a été légèrement tournée
c'est pour ça qu'on voit un peu de bleu
et de rose, et on pourrait la faire tourner complètement
voilà une rotation de cent quatre-vingts degrés
donc on a ces notions de phase que le quantique nous offre
trois super-pouvoirs qui se manifestent dans les qubits
ce sont les pouvoirs de la superposition
le pouvoir de l'interférence
et le pouvoir de l'intrication
alors regardons ça — le principe de superposition est en fait
assez simple à comprendre
donc l'étoile sur la gauche
on est soit au pôle nord zéro soit au pôle sud un
et si on additionne ces deux états
on obtient un qubit en superposition qui a à la fois
zéro et un simultanément, nord
et sud — maintenant le diagramme de droite c'est pareil
mais là on va faire un petit truc
on va appliquer un gate, un quantum gate
sur ce qu'on a fait ici, rappelle-toi
on peut changer — on peut maintenant
faire tourner ces petites lunes, non ?
donc on l'a fait tourner de cent
quatre-vingts degrés et maintenant on a un
donc maintenant quand on fait l'addition de zéro plus un, on se retrouve
avec un état de superposition
mais remarque que c'est différent
et celui de gauche on est
toujours zéro et un mais maintenant avec un état tourné
pour le un — maintenant ça va être très puissant
pour exploiter une deuxième chose vraiment intéressante qui est
le principe d'interférence
et ce n'est pas une opération qu'on peut effectuer en classique
dans le monde des bits — donc ici dans cet exemple on a
un zéro et un sur la gauche plus
ce nouvel état qu'on a créé
qui est aussi zéro et un
mais avec cette lune tournée — quand on fait ça maintenant
on peut faire interférer ces deux états
et remarque qu'il s'est passé quelque chose de vraiment intéressant
on a annulé l'état un
et on s'est retrouvé avec l'état zéro
on a fait ça parce qu'on a fait interférer les états
donc la prochaine possibilité qu'on a maintenant
c'est : combien d'états peut-on créer ?
et ce qui est beau dans le quantique c'est qu'on peut créer un nombre exponentiel
d'états — regardons un système qui a
cinq qubits — dans ce cas on représente ces qubits
comme des qubits indépendants, non ? tu les vois à gauche
des zéros et des uns qui se multiplient, on en a cinq
donc le nombre d'états qu'on peut créer, bas ou
un ordinateur quantique représenté sur cette sphère à droite
c'est deux à la puissance
du nombre de qubits qu'on a — dans ce cas on en a cinq
donc deux à la puissance cinq c'est trente-deux états
donc on voit trente-deux de ces petites lunes
remarque que dans ce cas on n'a pas intégré
de phase — elles sont toutes roses — l'aspect puissant
d'utiliser cette propriété appelée intrication dans le monde quantique
c'est qu'on peut créer maintenant des états
comme celui représenté à droite
où on a ces combinaisons de rose
et de bleu où cet état ne peut pas être décrit
comme le produit indépendant de
ces cinq qubits — dans ce cas
puisqu'on a trente-deux états
ce que ça nous dit c'est en fait quelque chose de très profond